FLASHIER.
CHRIS: A BIG TRADE INVOLVING A
FORMER M.V.P., RUSSELL WESTBROOK
IT HAS BEEN REPORTED, THE GUY
WHO AVERAGED A TRIPLE-DOUBLE FOR
HIS FOURTH TIME IN FIVE SEASONS
IS NOW A MEMBER OF THE LAKERS.
THE WIZARDS GET IN RETURN KYLE
KUZMA, MONTREZL HARRELL,
KENTAVIOUS CALDWELL-POPE AND THE
22ND OVERALL PICK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS TRADE?
STEVE: I LOVE IT.
RUSS IS GETTING A CHANCE TO GO
BACK TO L.A., PLAYING WITH
LEBRON AND ANTHONY DAVIS.
IT IS CRAZY TO SAY THAT THIS
GUY, WITH THAT MOTOR, TAKES THE
PRESSURE OFF LEBRON FOR ME.
IN A FASTBREAK SITUATION, WE
KNOW LEBRON IS ONE OF THE BEST
BUT PUSHING PACE, CREATING
TEMPO, I THOUGHT THEY NEEDED
SOMEBODY ELSE.
I THOUGHT DENNIS SCHRODER WAS
GOING TO BE THAT GUY.
HE WAS OK, BUT THIS IS A GUY WHO
IS GOING TO TAKE A FEW PEOPLE
WITH HIM, DUNK IT, PASS IT, EVEN
IF HE MISSES, THAT GIVES SO MANY
OFFENSIVE LANES FOR EVERYBODY.
PEOPLE DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND,
HIS PASSING AND SEEING THE GAME
HAS GOTTEN BETTER.
SOMETIMES YOU CAN GET ASSISTS
BUT RIGHT NOW HE KNOWS WHERE HE
WANTS TO GO.
HE HAS SETTLED INTO BEING A
VETERAN AND HE WANTS TO WIN.
HE PLAYS EXTREMELY HARD.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS FANTASTIC.
CHRIS: GO AHEAD.
BRIAN: IT WAS TWO SHORT YEARS
AGO THAT I WAS COACHING IN L.A.
AND I LIKE RUSSELL GOING BACK TO
HIS HOMETOWN.
THE QUESTION I HAVE IS, WHAT
STYLE OF PLAY THEY ARE GOING TO
PLAY.
FRANK VOGEL TYPICALLY, HIS TEAMS
HAVE BEEN TOWARDS THE BOTTOM OF
THE LEAGUE IN TERMS OF SCORING
OUTPUT IN THE LEAGUE AND PACE OF
PLAY.
RUSSELL WESTBROOK THRIVES IN
THE FASTBREAK, GETTING OUT IN
THE OPEN AND PUTTING PRESSURE ON
THE DEFENSE AND ATTACKING THE
RIM.
KYLE KUZMA, WHO THEY ARE LOSING,
WAS IN MY ESTIMATION ONE OF THE
BEST LANE RUNNERS IN THE LEAGUE.
YOU TAKE THAT AWAY, YOU TAKE
AWAY KENTAVIOUS CALDWELL-POPE,
WHO WAS ONE OF THEIR BEST
DEFENDERS ON THE PERIMETER, A
GUY WHO COULD SPACE THE FLOOR
AND KNOCK DOWN SHOTS, WHERE IS
THE SHOOTING GOING TO COME FROM?
THEY LOST DANNY GREEN A COUPLE
YEARS AGO, AFTER THE
CHAMPIONSHIP SEASON.
THAT HURT THEM.
IF YOU HAVE RUSSELL PUSHING THE
BALL, I DON'T SEE LEBRON AT THIS
STAGE REALLY GETTING UP AND DOWN
THE FLOOR WITH HIM OR ANTHONY
DAVIS, FOR THAT MATTER.
WHAT STYLE OF PLAY THEY PLAY
WILL BE INTERESTING.
ANDY: AMONG THE BIG THREE THEY
HAVE, CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG,
HE IS ARGUABLY THE ONE THAT
WOULD BE THE HEALTHIEST.
CLEARLY, WE HAVE SEEN WITH A.D.
AND LEBRON, THEY HAVE BEEN
BANGED UP.
THEY HAVE MISSED A LOT OF GAMES.
WITH WESTBROOK, YOU CAN AT LEAST
FEEL LIKE YOU ARE MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE ONE OF YOUR M.V.P.'S OUT
THERE ON A CONSISTENT BASIS,
BECAUSE IT MIGHT BE HARD TO
PROJECT THAT YOU ARE ALWAYS
GOING TO GET ALL THREE OR
CERTAINLY, A.D. AND LEBRON.
STEVE: FAIRPOINT.
LEBRON CAN'T PLAY FOREVER.
I TAKE OFF MY HAT TO HIM AND
DAVIS HAS BEEN, LOTS OF NAGGING
INJURIES.
I THINK WESTBROOK PLAYS THROUGH
HIS INJURIES.
WHAT THEY PUT AROUND THEM WILL
HELP THOSE GUYS.
THOSE GUYS RIGHT NOW ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO FIND AND DEVELOP
OTHER GUYS FOR THEM TO BE GREAT.
RUSSELL WILL BE EXCITING.
IT IS GOING TO BE INTERESTING TO
SEE.
I CAN SEE RIGHT NOW, LEBRON
ASKING FOR IT, RUSSELL ASKING
FOR IT.
IT'S GOING TO BE GOOD TO WATCH.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS.
CHRIS: INTERESTING, YOU SAID ONE
OF THOSE OTHER M.V.P.'S,
LEBRON'S CAREER, THIS WOULD BE
THE THIRD FORMER M.V.P. HE HAS
PLAYED WITH.
SHAQ IN 2010, THE TAIL END OF
HIS CAREER, THEN DERRICK ROSE
PLAYED 16 GAMES WITH LEBRON IN
2017-2018.
AS MANY GREAT PLAYERS AS LEBRON
HAS PLAYED WITH, A FORMER
M.V.P., THIS WILL BE THE FIRST
TIME A GUY IS IN THE MIDDLE OF
HIS CAREER.
RUSSELL WESTBROOK DID HAVE THIS
TWEET, THANK YOU D.C., YOU
WELCOMED ME AND MY FAMILY WITH
OPEN ARMS FROM DAY ONE.
EVERYONE FROM THE FRONT OFFICE
AND TRAINING STAFF TO COACHES,
TEAMMATES, FANS.
I'M GRATEFUL YOU TOOK A CHANCE
AND SUPPORTED ME EVERY STEP